resuelve este sistema si te das cuenta
que tenemos otra vez tres ecuaciones y
tres en cuentas por lo tanto lo que se
me ocurre es resolver a este sistema por
eliminación o suma o resta más o menos
como lo hice en el vídeo pasado lo que
voy a hacer es eliminar
una variable de estas tres ecuaciones
para que me quede un sistema mucho más
fácil y lo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que en esta tercera ecuación tenemos
aquí a menos z por lo tanto si yo
multiplico esta ecuación por 2 y por 5
voy a poder cancelar tanto la segunda
ecuación con la tercera ecuación y la
primera ecuación con la segunda ecuación
cuando yo escale el plano o la ecuación
número 3 que tengo aquí entonces voy a
poder eliminar una de estas tres
variables y por lo tanto resolver el
sistema así que me voy a tomar de nuevo
la primera ecuación que dice x + 2 + 5 z
igual a menos 17 y lo que voy a hacer es
tomar la tercera ecuación y la voy a
multiplicar por 5 para que se cancele la
zeta entonces aquí lo voy a multiplicar
por 5 y me queda 3 por 5 es 15 15 x más
5 por 15 5 james 15 x más 5 y menos 5 z
menos 1 por 5 es menos 5 menos 5 z es
igual a 3 por 5 lo cual es 15 3 por 5 es
15 y entonces date cuenta que si yo
estas dos ecuaciones entonces se va a
cancelar la zeta y me queda 15 x más una
x es 16 x 2 yemas incluye 7 james estos
dos se cancelan que es justo lo que yo
quería de aquí y de estos dos se va a la
zeta y me queda siempre sencillamente
que menos 17 más 15 es menos 2 16 x más
7 y es igual a menos 2 y ya tengo una
nueva ecuación con solamente dos
incógnitas en esta nueva ecuación no
aparece la zeta por lo tanto solamente
tengo como incógnita a la x de la yema y
esto salió de trabajar la primera con la
tercera ecuación ahora me voy a tomar la
segunda ecuación que dice 2x menos tres
más 12 está igual a menos 16 y voy a
trabajar otra vez con la tercera
ecuación con la tercera ecuación porque
tienen menos z aquí es decir que si yo
multiplico esta ecuación por 2 que me va
a quedar lo que me va a quedar es menos
12 y entonces se va a poder cancelar con
este más 12 está positivo que tengo aquí
así que vamos a multiplicar los 2 por 13
6 6 x +
2 james menos 2 z 2 por menos 1 - 2 - 2
z es igual a 3 por 2 6 y entonces vamos
a sumar estas dos ecuaciones la ecuación
número 2 con la ecuación número 3 x 2 y
me queda 2x 6x es 8x menos tres más dos
y es menos 10 estos dos se cancelan se
van y del otro lado me queda menos 16
más 6 lo cual es menos 10 y si te das
cuenta ya aquí tampoco tengo a la zeta
por lo tanto ya tengo una nueva ecuación
que solamente tiene la x el ay en la
cual puede operar con la ecuación que me
había resultado hace rato de la ecuación
de amarillo y entonces tengo un sistema
de ecuaciones con dos incógnitas y con
dos ecuaciones y pues bueno pues vamos a
resolverlas y qué te parece si yo
multiplico esta ecuación por 7 porque
entonces me va a quedar menos 7 lo cual
se va a eliminar con 7 y fíjate bien 7
por 8 56 x 7 x menos y es menos 7 james
y después 7 x menos 10 es menos 70 y
ahora sí vamos a sumar estas dos
ecuaciones para resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones
solamente dos incógnitas y que me va a
quedar 1656 es 72 6 y 6 12 y llevamos
unos 72 72 x después de esos 2 evans y
del otro lado me queda menos 2 menos 70
en lo cual es menos 72 perfecto y ahora
lo que voy a hacer es dividir ambos
lados de la ecuación entre 72 y después
me queda 72 72 se van y me queda que x
es igual a menos 1 es decir menos 72
entre 72 y ya tengo el valor de x una
vez que ya obtuve el valor de x lo que
voy a hacer es sustituir el valor de x
en esta ecuación en esta ecuación que
tengo aquí para encontrar el valor de
james y me queda 8 x menos 1 lo cual es
menos 8 menos y es igual a menos 10 y de
aquí voy a despejar alguien por eso ver
sumar 8 y me va a quedar del lado
izquierdo estos dos se van y me quedan
menos james mientras que el lado derecho
me queda menos 2 y si multiplicó a /
menos 1 ambos lados de la ecuación me
queda que es igual a 2 perfecto ya tengo
el valor de x ya tengo mi valor de y
pues ahora vamos a encontrar el valor de
se está sustituyendo la ex ley
estas tres ecuaciones que por cierto
esta es la que se vea mucho más sencilla
de resolver por lo tanto me queda 3x más
bien menos 73 este de aquí y lo voy a
escribir por acá 3x pero x vale menos
uno entonces es tres por menos uno más
pero lleva el de dos entonces esto más 2
- se está igual a 3 3 por unos menos
tres más dos menos se está igual a tres
y después si sumo estos dos le queda
menos uno menos igual a tres si sumo uno
de ambos lados de la ecuación que me va
a quedar más uno más uno esté uno y este
uno se cancelan y simple y sencillamente
me queda menos z del lado izquierdo
menos 7 es igual a 4 y multiplicando por
menos 1 me va a quedar que z es igual a
menos 4 y perfecto ya tengo el valor de
x de jay-z que satisfacen las tres
situaciones simultáneamente parece ser
que esta es nuestra solución y para ver
que no me he equivocado aún lo que voy a
hacer es sustituir esos tres valores en
las tres ecuaciones como un método de
comprobación así que me voy a tomar la
primera actuación y dice x + 25 z igual
a menos 10
- 12 por 24 5 por menos 4 lo cual me da
menos 20 esto debe de ser igual a menos
17 aquí estrés positivo 3 positivo menos
20 es menos 17 perfecto
ya tengo que la primera si cumple ahora
vamos con la segunda vamos a ver si
estos tres valores y satisfacen la
segunda y me queda dos por equis es
menos dos menos tres por jay menos tres
por dos es menos seis más 12 está más
dos por menos cuatro es menos ocho y
esto tiene que ser menos 16 y es menos 2
menos 6 menos 8 menos 8 menos 16 - 2 -
otros menos 10 menos 6 es menos 16
perfecto otra menos ahora vamos a
comprobar la última dice 3x más jay-z es
igual a 33 por menos unas menos 3
27 pero menos por menos me da más sería
más 4 - 3 24 esto tiene que ser igual a
tres y menos tres más dos es menos 14 es
33 positivo perfecto también cumple la
tercera es decir que ya encontramos los
valores de x de jay de z que satisfacen
las tres ecuaciones al mismo tiempo
encontramos el punto de intersección de
estos tres planos en r3